welcome everyone can everybody hear me
okay all right nice to see you all so
apparently this part is you know there's
a bad bird or something underneath that
but hopefully it won't be disruptive my
name is Rebecca I'm gonna talk about
sort of two things that I spend a lot of
time thinking about one is a text
analysis so I do a lot of work in
natural language processing in my day
job and then my other kind of big
passion is in visual diagnostics for
machine learning so using plotting
routines as a way to get some
introspection into the models that I
build and to kind of know when I'm you
know going in the right direction and
going away from the right direction and
so this talk has sort of a fusion of
those two things it's a little bit of an
experiment and so I'm very excited to
hear what your thoughts are you know if
any of these things sort of resonate
with you but I will say that this is
sort of aimed at a novice sort of
beginning level machine learning
practitioner so you know I'm sort of not
going to presume very much about what
your prior experiences performing
machine learning performing natural
language processing or doing visual
Diagnostics so there we go this is me um
I like Larry said I lead the data
science team at icx media it's a small
digital media analytics company here in
DC and the co-creator of yellow brick
which we'll talk about in a little while
and please remind me at the end I have
stickers laptop stickers for yellow
brick brought them with me thanks also
to Larry for reminding me to bring the
stickers so I'm happy to give out
stickers to anybody who would like some
yellow brick the big news with yellow
brick is that we recently became the
newest num focus affiliated project so
we like that for us is like hitting the
big time in the open source world
so come and get a sticker while you can
I'm also one of the co-authors of
applied text analysis with Python which
is an O'Reilly title that was published
in June of the summer okay so I'm gonna
do a quick review again I said this is
sort of for a beginning machine learning
audience or novice machine learning
audience so essentially this is the this
is what we do when we do machine
learning so we have some data we call
those may be examples or samples or
instances we have some n number of
samples of data and we're going to
assume that each sample is represented
by more than one thing right so maybe
this is a table and we have a number of
rows and each row is an instance and
each column is some some part of that
instance something that characterizes
that point and so what we need to do is
create a model that is able to predict
unknown properties so you know let's say
if we have some new data where we don't
know something about it but it has the
same kind of general patterns of the
original training data we should be able
to predict something about the new data
so let's kind of switch to a spatial
right so we're going to move from
thinking about data as a table you know
a spreadsheet or a data frame to
thinking about data as things that are
in space right so in this case each of
our points exists in some high
dimensional space and what we want to do
is try to figure out how to define
regions between those points that are
meaningful in some way and so hopefully
those regions are things that will allow
us to make these predictions so maybe in
some cases we want to be able to draw
lines or curves sometimes we want to be
able to kind of do hyper spirits fears
around our points
so that we can differentiate between
different types of points if we're doing
classification let's say or maybe what
we want to be able to regress or cluster
them ok so so now we're all on the same
page in terms of our terminology right
so we have instances these are our maybe
our rows or in the spatial
interpretation these are the points in
space they're composed of features and
those features in our tabular kind of
interpretation or what make up the
dimensions in the spatial interpretation
right ok so what that means is that our
feature space is the end mentions where
our variables exist and this is all of
the variables up until the target
assuming we're doing some kind of
supervised machine learning problem we
have a target and so that's not part of
the dimensionality but everything else
in you know in our table is going to add
a dimension so feature extraction then
is what we do on the kind of original
data to try to create some space where
prediction is going to be possible so
let's kind of take a real-world example
right so let's say we have a bunch of
instances and each instance is an
instance of a tire so each row is a tire
in our data set and each column is some
information about that tire and what we
would like to predict is how thick the
tires are after we've done after we've
put them through the paces after we've
done some testing and so let's say you
know the the columns that we have define
things like how far the travel is tired
and the travels the tires traveled in
the test that's a tongue twister how far
the tires traveled in the test and the
second column is maybe the duration of
the test right because you know it's not
just how far but how long we had the
tire is burning for right that's going
to
probably determine how thick or thin
they are after the testing period and
then maybe our third feature is
something to do with a chemical
preserving some sort of preservative
that's in the tire that's designed to
make them long wearing so in this case
how what's our dimensionality three okay
so it's and it's probably going to be
the positive quadrant of that three
dimensional space because all of these
things that we've talked about are
things that can't be negative probably
unless some miracle occurs time travel
so however we can also so now we're
going to do some feature engineering
right we're gonna do extraction we have
some intuition that we're going to be
able to do some things to some of our
columns to maybe get at a more
informative feature and that more
informative speed feature might be the
speed at which the tires were traveling
during the test right so it's not just
you know purely a function of how long
the tires were tested and how far the
test took the tires but if you were
going really really fast during the test
you know we kind of have an intuition
that that will have an impact on the
wear of the tires right so we're going
to extend our old feature space into a
new feature space so now we're going to
include a another dimension so now we
have how many dimensions four dimensions
right so we're going to do this mapping
that takes us from our original
dimensionality into this new
dimensionality and the hope is that this
new dimensionality allows us to more
easily draw you know some kind of
decision boundary so that we'll be able
to differentiate our tires in terms of
their targets maybe we're classifying
them into long wearing and short wearing
or maybe we're just trying to regress
although this makes it
like we're trying to classify the
picture okay so can we extend all of
these things to non numeric data
yes
maybe we're tentative maybe we can
extend this to non numeric data so in
fact a lot of the data that we work with
that you work with maybe is not numeric
out of the box right so maybe it's image
data who works with image data who works
with video data who works with sound
data who works with text data all right
so you all know what you coming for your
coming from it for a text analytics talk
so I kind of expected some NLP folks out
here right so our data doesn't start out
numeric but it has to get numeric
because why because we have to math it
right so we have to map it so we have to
turn it into numbers but this is a
little bit more of a transformation that
what we talked about in our last example
right so it's not as simple as dividing
two numbers and getting a speed this is
going to be a different kind of
transformation and so we should be
anticipating some some added complexity
here right um so here's the tricky part
right so machine learning is going to
rely on our but our ability to kind of
put points into space right to kind of
map things into numeric space so that we
can decide when to tires are close to
each other or far apart or when to
documents are close together or for our
part but when we make this
transformation from text data into
numeric data that spatial representation
is not straightforward all the time and
it's very easy to make mistakes and so
that's what we're going to talk about um
you know how do we decide how to
quantify distance between
numeric instances well there are a lot
of options here are just a few of them
this is sort of like the the cheat sheet
that we use when we're you know kind of
looking at text analytics problems you
know the go-to for most NLP so it has
anybody heard the rule of thumb of the
the kind of distance measure you should
always use when you're doing text
analytics you should always use cosine
distance except it's not distance you
should always use cosine right and so
and then you try to figure out why the
use cosine and the conversation sort of
like devolves into complexity we're
going to talk about that the default for
most numeric problems is what yeah it's
usually you know we're going to assume
Euclidean less proven otherwise in text
our choice of distance metric is is
really really important and can be
really dangerous so the the particular
challenges of modeling text data are
that text is extremely high dimensional
so if we are trying to let's say we want
to compare two books and we have you
know the Wizard of Oz and we have a
wrinkle in time how how many dimensions
do we have
we have a dimension for every word that
appears in the union of those two books
so every word that can occur in either
book is the dimensionality that we're
working in this is way bigger than four
dimensions in our original tire problem
so these are massive vectors right this
is non trivial in terms of big right so
usually when you hear big data you're
thinking big in terms of how many rows
but here we're talking about big data
also in the sense that there are a lot
of dimensions a lot of columns in our
original metaphor the other thing is
that it's extremely sparsely distributed
so in the case that we're comparing say
The Wizard of Oz and a wrinkle in time
you know maybe those two books share a
lot of words but if we're going to
compare you know a Kanye West tweet with
a wrinkle and time we're going to end up
with you know Kanye West's tweet is
going to be represented as an extremely
sparse vector right so it'll mostly be
composed of zeroes right so most of the
words that appear in a Wizard of Oz are
not going to appear in Kanye West's
suite just because he's limited by
characters right not by his vocabulary
so you know so we have this problem of
you know how are we going to compare
these extremely different vectors you
know this one vector that's going to be
extremely populated and is going to have
a lot of ones in it you know it's gonna
have almost all ones in it you know I
maybe unless he has some interesting
words in his tweet you know we're gonna
have one book vector that has a whole
lot of ones in it and the other vector
is going to be mostly zeros how do we
compare those two that's that's tricky
to compare also we're going to have do
you mind if we hold questions until the
we're also going to have some features
that are a lot more important than other
features so you know if we're comparing
documents about hobbies you know the you
know let's say we want to cluster all of
the you know sporting documents and
we're hoping that we'll get a cluster
you know nice clusters of basketball and
baseball and soccer let's say you know
the dimension of the word of is not
going to be very informative overall
it's not going to really help us cluster
and differentiate those hobbyist
documents the dimension of the word you
know the token basketball is probably
going to be a lot more informative in
forming those clusters in addition we're
gonna have some future variations that
matter a lot more than other future
variations right so we can't kind of
rely on the fact that you know just
because a feature is there at all and
that it's you know maybe somewhat unique
that it's important in doing some kind
of differentiation so you know let's say
we're trying to classify garden books
you know maybe the words tree and
horticulture both appear frequently but
you know the word tree gets used in
other context it gets used in math
textbooks too right so it might not be
good enough to think about the frequency
of tree as important as being as
important as the frequency of the word
horticulture because it's only going to
be maybe the word horticulture that
helps us successfully differentiate the
gardening books so what do we do right
okay so open source to the rescue cycle
urn has a lot of distance metrics
probably not probably more than you've
experimented with in scikit-learn the
default distance metric for at least all
of the scikit-learn models that i have
experimented with is always
euclidian right and that's that's
sensible right that's a sensible default
because what scikit-learn developed for
doing text analysis no designed for
doing you know machine learning on
numeric data
you know organically numeric data let's
say and and so it makes sense for them
to default Euclidean and scikit-learn is
also amazing because the API sort of
plugs in those defaults without you know
without signaling that it's plugging
them in so it's just going to do it
under the hood and not say anything and
so you may be using euclidean distance
and not even know it and you know
scikit-learn has you know a bunch of
actually just a pairwise distance
measures implemented and some of which
we'll talk about but it turns out that
you know you can use really almost
anything from sy PI's spatial distance
module also just out of out of the box
so though it'll work seamlessly with
scikit-learn which means sorry my slides
are a little bit cut off but um you know
what this means is that you have a lot
of distance measures to choose from the
note down here says that they don't all
work for sparse input as far as matrix
input format which can collide with some
of the scikit-learn estimators so just
be warned but you have a lot of options
so what I would propose to you is that
you consider using yellow-brick to help
you decide which distance measure is the
one that is most appropriate for your
datasets yellow-brick is a pure Python
machine learning library that is
designed to enhance the model selection
process so it is modeled on top of the
scikit-learn api so if you already using
scikit-learn it will sort of work
seamlessly with all of the estimators
that you use and it essentially it's an
it's one more import statement at the
top and but it's essentially wrapping
that fit and predict cycle that you're
already familiar with and
on top of that common Maps hot lab
plotting routines that allow you to
introspect the model that you've
selected to see if it kind of correct or
if it's improving if you are you know
doing gradient ascent or descent and
really the idea is that model selection
should not be a random walk right you
should be purposefully moving towards
models that are more performant and not
just kind of picking the top five from
kaggle today and using those hyper
parameters and hoping that they also
work for you are completely different
datasets so the specific model that I
wanted to kind of show you from from
yellow-brick is the t-sne so it's
stochastic neighbor embedding so what T
Snee does is it applies some kind of
dimensionality reduction so in our case
it does a singular value decomposition
by default but it could just as easily
be a principal component analysis and it
does this for for efficiency of
computation and then it embeds the
resulting vectors using the probability
distributions from the original
dimensionality and the reduced you know
decompose dimensionality and then
because it's yellow brick and it's kind
of wrapping these plotting routines it
executes a scatter plot and so what you
see here in this example plot is a
projection of about 400 documents that
have been you know vectorized you know
so turned into numeric vectors and then
you know projected using a stochastic
neighbor embedding plot using yellow
brick and the colors you can actually
color by class so even though you know T
Snee is generally used for clustering
problems if you know the classes in
advance you can toggle on
coloring by class so what this does is
it shows us how effectively the the
stochastic neighbor embedding captured
the class behavior how are we doing on
time we good I don't have a clock okay
so we have I wanted to sort of underline
that distance is sort of not a single
single problem single solution kind of
thing even that kind of rule of thumb
about always using cosine distance for
text analysis problems does not always
work and so what I would like to suggest
is that you should be brave to
experiment with a bunch of the distance
measures that are implemented in
scikit-learn and inside pi and then
couple that with visual diagnostic tools
like the tease me plot from yellow brick
to gauge whether or not the distance
measure is effectively capturing the
behavior of your specific data set so in
order to illustrate this I picked a few
different data sets these are all from
the UCI machine learning repository
they're all easy to find and so in the
first case this is the Hobie's corpus
that we saw on the previous slide this
is also one of the you know one of the
data sets that comes with yellow brick
when you pip install yellow brick
there's also these other two the farm
adds corpus which is a two class problem
essentially it's a bunch of data from a
a farming ad corpus where farmers had to
select ads that they wanted to appear on
their web pages and so they can either
basically upvote or downvote so that's
what the two classes are so they voted
yes I want this ad on my web page or no
I don't want this out of my web page and
so in general the doc length there is
you know they're short documents the
documents are just the tags the metadata
tags that characterize the ads so they
say things like you know food or
McDonald's or swatch or technology or
something
like that our pregnancy and in fact
pregnancy is highly correlated with
downvotes and farmer ads interestingly
enough and the dress attributes sales
corpus is another UCI repo dataset
it's a corpus of 500 dresses represented
as their features and in this case every
dress has the same number of features
right so every document is the same
length whereas for the other two corpora
the documents are varying lengths right
and so this is you know common that
you'll have kind of documents that are
very different lengths but in some cases
you're going to have some kind of data
set where you have maybe a single word
you know for each dimension
okay so let's we'll start off with
Euclidean distance this is kind of our
base assumption using scikit-learn
models we're going to assume a Euclidean
space and so Euclidean space is the
straight line distance between any two
points and that holds true you know even
after we have converted our documents
into words in space and so in order to
do a visualization of how these these
corpora behave using euclidean distance
will create a will instantiate a TC
visualizer using yellow brick so TC
visualizer is one of the objects one of
the classes that's implemented in the
yellow brick library and we'll pass in
metric equals Euclidian then we'll call
fit and poof
so poof is like the show method for
yellow brick and it's not show because
we didn't want to collide with show
because that already exists within that
pot live and so we're gonna fit
roll-call fit on our documents and our
labels and we'll call poof's and the
result is this so for our hobbies corpus
our ads corpus and our dresses corpus
and so I think one of the most
interesting observations right away is
that you know our euclidean distance has
done a terrible job of representing the
difference between some of these kinds
of instances you know particularly in
the hobbies corpus we can see that the
yellow points so these correspond to
this the documents related to sports
these are fairly cohesive you can see
some yellow points kind of spread out
but most of them are fairly tightly
clustered and also you know the the pink
points which here represent the
documents related to gaming they're also
fairly well clustered with some
variations the ads corpus you know the
green the not accepted ads you know are
fairly well clustered to accept that the
accepted ads you know there's a lot of
overlap there so we're not getting like
great separable 'ti there with the
dresses corpus we kind of have a little
bit of a mess right so Euclidean
distance is not doing us any favors here
so let's try something else
Manhattan distance also known as taxicab
or city block distance is the sum of the
absolute difference of the Cartesian
coordinates right and so this is often
represented using you know of
visualization like this where instead of
looking at the you know Euclidean
distance which is the green line right
the straight line distance we're looking
at kind of if you were a taxi in New
York how would you get from you know one
point to the other so again with yellow
brick the only thing that's different
about what we're doing here in the code
is that we're passing in metric equals
city block
and here are the resulting TC
visualizations so observations
potentially this is doing slightly
better for the ads corpus than our than
our Euclidean straight euclidean
distance it looks to be potentially
worse for the dresses corpus with with
maybe the exception of you know that
green cluster but you know the the
yellow in our hobbies corpus is now more
spread out the sports documents are more
diffused than they were so it looks like
we're getting worse okay so it sounds
like we don't we don't like this one
let's try something else
so chebyshev distance is checkerboard
distance right and so this is a
different you know a slightly different
way about thinking about distance so you
know it's a way to sort of say how far
away are we from this point are we one
block are we two blocks are we three
four five so this is a different way of
quantifying distance between instances
so um all we're gonna do here is we're
gonna pass in metric equals chebyshev's
and we're gonna see the results what do
we think thumbs up thumbs down
I think that you know the the second
cluster here in our dresses corpus maybe
you know is is fairly tight I'm not
feeling great about the other ones so
let's try something else how about
generalization of those other distance
measures so Minkowski is a
generalization of the last couple of
distance measures that we looked at and
it is a you know a way to define you
know kind of in in some general case you
know distance in a normalized vector
space so we're gonna pass in metric
equals Minkowski that's not super
excited all right maybe not this time
but there are gonna be some cases I'll
just let you know Minkowski often is
very good with text data so don't throw
it out the window it didn't work out for
these these guys here
in fact the Hobie's corpus I feel like
you know the Hobby it's doing not
terribly with the hobbyist corpus from
my perspective compared to Euclidean how
about Mahalanobis distance so
Mahalanobis distance is another one of
my goat cheese that I frequently
experiment with text data and the reason
is that it allows you to rescale the
dimensions a little bit you get to
rescale the coordinates with respect to
distribution so it has a way of kind of
normalizing the space for you according
to how your documents are distributed so
what we're gonna do here is we're gonna
pass in Mahalanobis we're going to
specify here a method to say that it
needs to be exact and
so I'm starting to see some interesting
things here with the ads corpus namely
that you know there seems to be some
potential decision space forming where
there's you know a pretty good
distinction between the green and the
blue that we haven't seen in the past
examples the dresses corpus is still
struggling so it's you know Mahalanobis
distance is not you know really helping
us out that much and the Hobie's corpus
is not liking Mahalanobis very much
either
how about cosine distance alright this
is our favorite friend for a text
analysis although note cosine distance
not actually a distance measure because
it does not satisfy what right so
somebody somebody is going to call you
on that it might be in a job interview
it might be at the water cooler it might
be at like a hip party that you go to
but now you know the answer but even
though it does not sort of you know tech
it's not technically a distance measure
we can use it to quantify the just the
difference between documents and the way
that we do this is not looking at the
absolute different distance between
document a let's say and document B but
looking at the cosine of the angle so
here we're going to pass in metric
equals cosine
so we it was supposed to be perfect
cosine distance is supposed to be the
solution to all of our text analysis
problems you know it's maybe doing okay
it's the first time that I've sort of
felt like the there's some you know
pattern with our our dresses corpus I
feel like the the red is starting to
look pretty distinct from the blue but
you know it's maybe not not what you
were sort of expecting based on how how
much people talk about cosine distance
the power of cosine distance can bear
distance is a weighted version of
Manhattan distance and it's helpful when
you have data that's scattered around
some origin and so in the case of some
texts documents this might actually be
really helpful in fact for the ads
corpus what I found was that Canberra
distance was was probably the most
performant and again the T Snee plots
are a little bit stochastic so every
time you plot them they look a little
bit different so it's worth it to run
them a couple of times and sometimes you
can play with the hyper parameters a
little bit and kind of get things to
spread out a little bit so you can see a
little bit the nuance between between
the points Jaccard distance is one that
people always bring up with for text
distance so we pass in metric equals
jacquard what do you think we're gonna
get well that didn't work did it
so Jaccard distance is the kind of set
distance and so for certain kinds of
text problems it's going to be very good
but it's not sort of a one-stop-shop
right same thing with Hamming distance
Hamming distance is a way to quantify
the Edit distance between any two things
his an it's extremely popular for
certain kinds of text analysis problems
but for ours results in like strain
structure right that's not informative
at all so last slide
what I would like to sort of suggest is
that you know when you start out with a
new data set
you don't know always from the beginning
what combination of model and hyper
parameters and future engineering is
going to be the best for your problem
and so you should sort of make this
assumption that you're going to go
through the process of doing feature
engineering model selection hyper
premier tuning multiple times and that
you should be looking for improvement in
those iterations and what I hope you'll
see is that you can use things like
yellow-brick to help with those
iterations to see if you are getting
closer for instance to quantifying the
distance between your text documents or
if you're getting worse if you're
interested in doing text analysis we
actually have several other visualizers
in yellow-brick that are special for
doing text analytics this dispersion
plot here is one that's created by Larry
here so you're welcome to come up and
chat with him or our Kristen or me about
it she's another contributor Nathan here
in the audience is another yellow-brick
contributor you can come and chat us up
about these dispersion plots allow you
to see how words appear across documents
so you can look at the in the incidence
of words across your entire corpus which
can be really useful for feature
engineering multidimensional scaling for
these inter cluster distance Maps tells
you how dense and separate your clusters
are which is incredibly helpful when
you're clustering documents and our good
favorite frequency distributions which
show you you know it allows you to sort
of see what may be the most informative
features are for your documents and you
can kind of take this you know line from
ben shneiderman emeritus faculty at
University of Maryland who says you know
over over the first sort of like cluster
your documents first get that overview
and then zoom and filter on-demand to
get the details to tell you whether or
not you're going in the right direction
or in the wrong direction and hopefully
that will steer you well thank you very
much for your time
[Applause]
yes these are all yellow brick
visualizers
so all of those those distance measures
that we looked at are things that you
can use in scikit-learn they're they're
all compatible not with every estimator
so there are some estimators that only
really are only designed to work with
Euclidean and Euclidean type distances
but yeah so you know you it's not just
for visualization it's also for how you
actually kind of put those into your
scikit-learn estimators to define your
clustering problem or your
classification problem
so I think my answer is that it's this
is a tough one that this is one of those
things especially with text data that
the human in the loop gets you to the
answer faster than some you know
automated grid search that's going to
you know run for forever and then maybe
miss you know get stuck in a local
Maxima that's why we all will have jobs
still in there in the future right now
we're doing something like yep idea and
removing stop work and stuff like that
and like the process you showed is there
any way in those dimension reduction
techniques where you could just see a
set of words that are not variable
across your classes labels etc like okay
these are just junk words they're knock
and I'm like help you with maybe you're
more complicated algorithm down
yeah sure so you know you could you
could do something like let's say you
did this inter cluster inter cluster
distance map which is the you know the
one with the circles here so once you've
done clustering you have you know you
kind of have labels right so you can you
can annotate each of your instances with
that cluster label and if you feel
pretty confident that your clusters are
distinct so if they're meaningfully
different let's say you know you can use
that annotation then to decide for
future instances you know if they kind
of would be assigned to that same
cluster but you can also sort of say you
know what are the things that that all
of these clusters have in common right
so if there are if there is some subset
of words you know so once we've done our
annotation and we've added maybe we add
a target column to our original data set
that labels the you know original
instances with the cluster target so now
we can look at the set of the words that
occur across you know all of the
documents and you could do something
then like a frequent frequency
distribution of all of those words and
sort of say you know what is the stuff
that's appearing in all of these
documents because probably it's not
helping me cluster and so potentially
those are candidates for stop words
yeah so we do have some you know
techniques for kind of the feature
analysis part so you probably what you
would do is you would maybe you would
experiment with some of these things
using like a count vectorizer let's say
and you would do this and then you would
try again with the tf-idf vectorizer and
say you know did that change anything
you know if I'm if I'm just doing
straight frequency versus some kind of
normalization by you know oddness of
words in certain documents is that
changing kind of how you know how the
patterns behave and so I think you know
you kind of want to probably come up
with a set of things that you know you
want to try in the beginning and cycle
through all of those first and then use
those to inform your path forward so
probably you know starting with some
kind of naive set of stop words is a
good idea but it can be dangerous in
some cases usually the the stop words
that we all use this sort of come you
know cooked into scikit-learn or NL TK
are ones that are not going to be very
informative but you probably do need a
domain-specific list of stop words for
every new corpus unless you work with
the same corpus over and over you know I
always create a new list every time or
sometimes I'll just kind of do a
frequency distribution and and chop off
the you know the most frequent words and
also chop off you know the hape axes the
words that only occur once and try to
take you know the five thousand words
sort of in the middle and just use that
because five thousand dimensions is a
lot easier to work with and also you
kind of have that you know it's a it's
an alternative to doing stop words
removal it's just taking you know those
that chunk in the middle of the
frequency distribution that's not like
the most common words and not the you
know least commonly occurring words
cool do you want to contribute to
yellow-brick come and talk to me doctor
and maybe you can be a contributor okay
um so I use the classification heat map
and the confusion matrix like all the
time I do a lot of classification so
usually what I do is like clustering and
sort of say like are there patterns at
all and then once I feel like there are
patterns I use those patterns to cut try
to create labels and then I do cluster
classification and so I used the
classification visualizers frequently
and I also there's there's one actually
one that Larry worked on which is class
prediction error which is essentially a
way of sort of saying on a per class
basis it's kind of like a twist on
confusion the confusion matrix it's like
on a per class basis where is my model
messing up the most and when it messes
up what where does it think it's going
like which class does it think this this
class actually is and that's really
useful because sometimes you don't care
about classifying all of the data like
maybe there's just two or three classes
in the whole set of classes that are
relevant to your your feature and so it
doesn't matter if you don't classify if
the other ones very well you just have
to be good at classifying those ones and
so your you can kind of use that for you
know making hard choices sometimes to
sort of say all right well we got a we
got to launch this so we're going to go
with this because at least it's good at
classifying the two classes we care
about so that one I liked very much
[Applause]